merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier
dusoft ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion monsieur le
ministre si depuis 2004 les départements
assurent avec le concours de l'État le
versement de l'allocation au profit des
bénéficiaires du RSA l'exercice de cette
compétence a été et demeure au cœur de
bien des discussions entre département
et gouvernement successifs les
départements sont aussi en charge de
l'accompagnement social et ou
professionnelle de chaque bénéficiaire
cette politique publique participe et
c'est heureux à la cohésion sociale du
pays sans remettre en cause la
détermination des élus départementaux le
professionnalisme de leurs équipes et
tout en leur reconnaissant un certain
nombre de réussites il est à noter que
malgré la baisse significative du
chômage une longue liste de propositions
d'emplois restent non pourvu
les secteurs concernés sont diverses
serveurs de café restaurant agent
d'entretien ATSEM aide à domicile à
déménagère voire même professionnel de
l'animation socioculturelle de quoi
réinterroger légitimement la déquation
entre les parcours d'insertion proposés
et la réalité du marché de l'emploi je
sais Monsieur le Ministre que quelques
départements se sont portés volontaires
pour une expérimentation celle-ci fait
craindre à une importante association du
secteur social une réforme qui selon
elle s'apparente à un retour du servage
n'ayant aucun doute sur la volonté qui
vous anime en la matière pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre devant mes
collègues de la Chambre haute préciser
les contours de cette évolution des
politiques d'insertion et nous en donner
le calendrier
pour vous répondre la parole est obligé
du travail pleine emploi de l'insertion
Monsieur lishop Merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Dagbert
vous l'avez dit pendant la campagne des
élections présidentielles le président
de la République alors candidat a
réinterrogé les modalités et la réussite
du modèle et du l'outil qui est le RSA
RSA
héritier du RMC en 1988 avec cette
volonté et c'est une fierté notre modèle
social d'accorder et d'apporter un
concours minimum un revenu minimum
celles et ceux qui se retrouvent sans
revenu aujourd'hui les résultats en
matière d'insertion d'intégration
professionnelle de retour à l'emploi ne
sont pas des résultats satisfaisants ils
ne sont pas satisfaisants parce qu'un
rapport des la Cour des comptes l'a
montré au premier semestre de l'année
2022 s'étend après l'entrée dans le RSA
42% des bénéficiaires sont encore
bénéficiaires du RSA de manière
permanente ou de manière discontinue
mais extrêmement régulière de la même
manière s'étend après l'entrée dans le
RSA seul trois bénéficiaires sur 10 on
retrouve un emploi et seul un sur 10 à
retrouver un emploi stable ça nous
oblige et ça nous oblige à agir nous
pouvons continuer à croire ou à penser
que la société serait quitte de son
devoir de solidarité une fois qu'elle
aura attribué une indemnité d'un peu
moins de 600 euros à une personne
dépourvue de revenus la conviction du
gouvernement la conviction que défend
devant vous et que la société sera
quitte de son devoir solidarité le
scolaire a permis le retour à l'emploi
parce que l'emploi le travail et
l'élément d'émancipation d'autonomie de
dignité et la capacité à retrouver un
revenu comment allons-nous le faire nous
allons le faire avec un accompagnement
plus intensif des bénéficiaires du RSA
et je dis tout net devant vous il n'a
jamais été question ni de travail
gratuit ni de bénévolat obligatoire il
s'agit de formation au stagi
d'accompagnement il s'agit de
remobilisation collective et
individuelle mais il ne s'agit ni de
bénévolat obligatoire ni de travail
gratuit c'est important à souligner
parce que ça ne correspond pas au modèle
qui est le nôtre le président de la
République l'a dit le RSA est un droit
inconditionnel pour tous ceux qui sont
privés de revenus le devoir de la
puissance publique de toute la puissance
publique et de garantir offre
d'insertion et de formation adaptée
personnalisée partout sur le territoire
et de ce que ces deux concessions sont
remplies il y a une logique de droit et
devoirs pour faire en sorte que ceux qui
en bénéficient s'inscrivent dans ces
parcours de retour vers l'emploi et
d'insertion par l'emploi
[Musique]